So far our programs always do the same thing. I mean when when we run it a
second time, it does exactly what it did before.
>> I don't get it. We just learned about reading input. When you run the program
again with different inputs, it'll do something different.
>> That's not exactly what I mean. Whenever I run the program again, it runs exact
same lines of code. What if I only want to add a friend if the friend's not
already there?
>> I think the time has come to, to learn about programming decisions. Then your
program can take different actions depending on circumstances. For example, you
could skip the lines of code that do the adding if the friend's already in the
list. That's exactly what I want, let's do that.